-Welcome back, everybody.
We are hanging out with
the one and only Kristen Bell!
And we are about to play
a brand-new game
called "You Can Only Keep One."
-♪ You can only keep,
you can keep ♪
♪ You can only keep one ♪
-This is based on
the popular Internet trend.
Each round, I'm going to
give you three choices,
and you'll have to tell me
which of the three
you would keep
if you could only keep one.
-Okay.
-All right?
Let's see the first
three options. All right.
We have French fries,
curly fries, or waffle fries.
[ Audience ohhs ]
-How is anyone supposed to
make this decision?
-Well -- I know.
All right. Wait. Let's --
I've got an answer, I think.
You can only keep one.
-Okay, I think I do, too.
Let's see if we agree.
Let's say it at the same time.
-Hmm.
-Both: One, two, three.
-French fries.
-Curly fries.
-Wow! Wow!
-Why'd you pick French fries?
The most boring
of all the fries.
-It's also -- It's just classic.
-Okay.
-I went classic.
I just don't want
to see them go away.
And so I was just thinking
about the future and --
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, God. Wait. If we choose,
the rest of them go away?!
-No, no, no.
That's not part of the game.
No, they don't go away.
I was just thinking --
Well, you're the one
playing the game, not me.
All right. Next round.
Your options are --
This is a toughie.
"The Little Mermaid,"
"Aladdin," "Lion King."
-I gotta go.
-No, no, no. You can't go!
-I have to go.
I just found out
I'm not available right now.
[ Laughter ]
-Kristen!
-I'm so sorry.
-Look at this.
"Little Mermaid," "Aladdin,"
"Lion King."
Your kids are in that age.
I mean, these are classics.
-Jimmy.
Can I get fired from Disney
if I tell you my real answer?
[ Laughter ]
Do we think?
Like, can we have the lawyers
check into it?
Okay, okay. I'm going to go
with my gut instinct
'cause it was my favorite.
I got --
I think I got to keep "Aladdin."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Really?
-Yeah.
-"Aladdin."
-I really --
I like his scrappiness.
I loved Abu.
-I like the live version.
I saw the Broadway version.
That's good.
But you've got to go
"Little Mermaid," right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Lion King"?
[ Louder cheers and applause ]
"Lion King"
is the crowd favorite.
-Yeah, everybody loves
"Lion King."
It's not that I don't like
-Yeah, me too.
-I do like "Lion King."
I don't know why -- This is,
like, the har-- This is...
-No, this is so fun.
-...too difficult.
-No, this is too fun.
All right. Here's the next --
-This is so fun.
-Ready for this? How about this?
Meryl Streep in
"The Devil Wears Prada."
Meryl Streep in "Mamma Mia!"
Or Meryl Streep
in "Little Women."
Let's discuss.
[ Audience murmuring ]
People are walking out
right now.
They're freaking out.
"I can't take this."
-Well, don't -- But listen.
Everybody who's leaving,
stop for a second.
We're keeping
two out of three Meryls.
-Yes, yes.
-No.
-We're getting rid
of two out of three Meryls.
I'm not --
-Keeping one Meryl.
-Keeping one Meryl. Okay.
I'm gonna go with this.
'Cause it's --
The amount of times
I've had to watch "Mamma Mia!"
because my kids love it so much
recently.
It's got to be "Mamma Mia!"
-The audience likes that.
-And she's so cute
in "Mamma Mia!"
-Yeah, I'll go with that, too.
I --
"Devil Wears Prada," though.
She really --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Obviously, she killed it
in "The Devil Wears Prada."
-This next one is an insane one.
I think I know the answer
to the next one.
I'm gonna even write it down.
Do I have paper?
I'm gonna write it down.
This is kind of an easy one,
I think.
-That's a real desk, huh?
It's not a prop desk.
There's real paper
in real drawers?
-No, I planned this out.
I planned this bit out earlier.
So it's a fake --
-Oh, oh, okay.
-It's a real --
It's a working desk.
I spend all day
working from my desk.
[ Laughter ]
-It's practical. That's what
we say in the movie business.
-Yeah. That's so funny.
It actually is a working desk.
Yeah. But I don't use it --
Only for talking.
Yeah. Not for desking.
All right, ready for this?
This one's gonna
blow your mind.
-Okay.
-Red Starburst, pink Starburst,
yellow Starburst.
-No contest. No contest.
I know my answer.
-No contest.
[ Audience shouting ]
-'Cause two of them are gross,
and one of them rules.
That's how I know.
-Really?
-Pink.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All the way. 100%.
♪♪
This was the easiest one for me.
-I went with -- I went with red.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love red.
-See, Jimmy,
if there's one thing
that we've learned in life,
it's that we can
still be friends
even if we disagree.
-That's right.
That's the one thing
we can actually -- I love that.
All right, we can also split
a pack of Starburst
and both be really super happy.
-Exactly!
-All right, bud.
Starburst buddies for life.
Kristen Bell, everybody.
"Gossip Girl" premieres
July 8th on HBO Max.